[Music]
it is
seven o'clock good to have your company
this morning planes
trains and automobiles the government is
unveiling how it plans to decarbonize
the transport sector
as it attempts to meet the 2050 nets
evil target
we'll be asking the transport secretary
grant chats about that in
just a moment also coming up a
capital cover-up and the mayor of london
is making face masks mandatory on public
transport after the 19th
of july but will commuters take any
notice we'll be putting that to the
government plus we're also joined by
city can at half past seven uh also
this this program
a teenage globetrotter a quarter to ten
i'll be speaking to 18 year old travis
ludlow
who's just become the youngest person to
fly solo around the world
it is wednesday the 14th of july
the road to net zero transport sales of
petrol and diesel hgvs to be banned by
2040
but questions over whether it's
achievable and how it will be funding
this proposal is unrealistic alternative
hgvs
don't yet exist we don't know when
they'll exist
and we don't know how much they'll cost
a de facto amnesty the government's set
to end prosecutions related
to the northern ireland troubles in a
move opposed by people
and parties on both sides
as marcus rashford thanks fans for their
support after suffering racist abuse
a senior conservative backbencher says
the party needs to
rethink its attitude to taking the knee
some don't like it hot palm springs
sweats in california's heat wave
with one weather forecaster predicting
climate change will force some drastic
choices
we're going to get away from the
equators and start
inhabiting the north you know if you're
looking to invest in real estate
greenland is a great place to look right
now
and for the uk and ireland it's also
going to become increasingly
warm with some spots reaching heatwave
criteria
as we head into the weekend i'll have
the details for you later
morning all the government is unveiling
new plans to decarbonize the transport
sector
as it attempts to meet its target of net
zero carbon emissions by
2050 under the plans the sale of new
petrol or diesel hgvs will be banned by
2040
10 years after the same ban comes into
force for cars
but leaders in the haulage industry have
criticized the proposal
saying it is unrealistic our climate
change correspondent hannah thomas peter
has our first report green energy it's
it's our future yeah we can't rely on
coal
anymore or diesels
thomas has been driving trucks for a
decade he knows that transport is the
uk's largest contributor to emissions
and agrees that needs to change but as
part of its drive to decarbonize the
sector
the government has announced there'll be
no new diesel hgv
sold after 2040 a big change
at an uncertain time we are the most
important
chain in this instead of distribution
chain without without without us
there will be nothing on the shelves
nothing fresh on the shelves
at the supermarket no new shoes no new
jackets
i think we are very important
the plan has left an industry still
grappling with hydrogen and electricity
as alternatives
feeling adrift this proposal is
unrealistic alternative hgvs
don't yet exist we don't know when
they'll exist
and we don't know how much they'll cost
and it's not clear what any
transition will look like so this is
blue skies thinking
way ahead of real life reality
trucking isn't the only industry
affected by new targets the department
for transport is also pledging to get
domestic aviation
carbon emissions down to net zero by
2040
that's 10 years earlier than previously
promised
but the decarbonization of our world
isn't straightforward
and when it comes to planes for example
the technology used to make them greener
is still very much in development and
it's expensive
in fact money seems to be the key issue
here
the government criticized for producing
policy without a plan
yet to help pay for it unless we see
action now from the treasury and from
rishi thunak
the decarbonizing transport plan and any
plan on climate
that comes over the coming weeks won't
deliver what it needs to
the transport secretary thinks otherwise
of course long-term decisions about you
know how the the roads are paid for
are matters for the treasury that's not
what we're addressing today but what we
are doing is launching a plan which is
quite literally well beating amongst
major economies
that may be true but this roadmap
contains a series of
big gambles that the markets consumers
technology and the government's own
purse string holders
will all deliver as we march towards net
zero
hannah thomas peter sky news heathrow
i'm very pleased to say we're joined
once again on the programme by the
transport secretary grant shaps mr
schatz very good morning to you
good morning do take us through the
plans i mean
you heard hannah thomas peter there in a
report pointing out the fact that
that some are suggesting uh the what it
amounts to
are series of significant gambles on the
part of the government i suspect you
disagree with that
yeah i mean is a big uh challenge
there's no doubt about that at all
uh and i know the transport
decarbonization plan something sounds a
bit dull
but actually this is the most
far-reaching profound
changes uh we will have ever seen to our
transport network
um and it's a plan which is more
ambitious than anything that's been set
out by
any major economy in in the world um and
i what i'd say is i think that by
getting there first by
doing these uh making these decisions
setting the path
now we can give ourselves an example for
the future and we've already been doing
that
by for example um saying that there'd be
an end to sale of petrol and diesel cars
by
2030 and completely by 2035 even the
hybrids
and in doing so we've ended up you know
seeing those big announcements about
jobs in ellesmere port for vauxhall
and uh in sunderland for nissan in the
last week or so
building gigafactories bringing the
green jobs to the uk
so i think there's a big advantage to
sort of getting out there first and
setting out in considerable detail which
is what this plan does today
it is perhaps though um minister the the
reason that no one else
has gone as far as this government is
because a lot of what you're talking
about is
as yet impossible i mean you heard the
road hollidge association
in hannah's report pointing out the fact
you want to move away from from diesel
and petrol hgvs the problem is of course
we don't have any alternatives to diesel
perpetuates gvs currently
yes i should point out that the bigger
of the logistics organizations logistics
uk who also deal with
uh the haulier sector says that the plan
provides confidence and clarity
um so uh i think actually it is true to
say that not all the technology is there
at the moment but if you look at the
total
uh co2 carbon produced by transport
in 2019 ninety percent of it came from
the roads
and seventy percent of that came from
cars and vans and the cars and vans part
of it
the technology is already there lots of
people already drive
uh electric vehicles one in seven cars
sold this year had a plug on the end of
it
uh essentially so you know we've already
got large parts of the technology
undeniably we need the technology for
the rest and we're investing
uh in lots of different um
research to make sure that we can have
sort of carbon free
travel for the hgvs for coaches for
lorries for
buses and then for other forms of
transport including maritime including
aviation
where the work is actually already very
much advanced
it should wouldn't wouldn't it also be
advantageous to take advantage of
all of the powers that are within your
grasp at the moment sorting out for
example the fact that
currently you know train trips are still
50 more expensive than
than than flying on the same route you
know we know that local authorities
in terms of investment and local bus
services we've seen that diminish over
the past few years i mean there are a
lot of things that we can do to get
people out of their cars
out of petrol guzzlers and onto public
transport but we don't seem so
keen there's lots of things we can do
but we're massively keen
i must have missed you that morning but
i came on the program on sky
and announced the uh bus back better
which is our our plan for
for buses it's a three billion pound bus
bus plan uh which does exactly what you
you just said which is to get people
onto the
onto the bus network um just a few weeks
ago
i launched um great british railways as
a concept which will bring our railways
together
and enable much better clearer transport
for people
more efficiently run trains uh more on
time
and so on and so forth so i agree
entirely these other forms of transport
and public transport
in particular need to be really
attractive so we can get people on to
those forms of transport
and we've already made some very big
very significant announcements in in
that area
this transport decarbonisation plan
today is first of all
a large document as you might expect
which talks about all of the
uh different aspects but it's also then
supported by nine different
technical documents and consultations
into all areas
of transport with the idea that we
become
uh the the fastest decarbonizing
transport economy in the world with all
the jobs that that can provide as we've
seen in ellesmere port and
in sunderland just in the last week or
so
let's talk covert 19 uh for a few
moments if we can minister and and
you'll obviously be aware
of this recant transport for london
announcing this morning
that the waiting of masks will remain
mandatory uh on the tube and on bus
networks
in london what do you make of that i i
suppose you must disagree with it
no i was on uh either your program or
sky uh just the end of the last week
saying that
whilst we're going from this being a
legal requirement to guidelines we do
expect individual
carriers you know the transport
organizations uh to make sure that they
are
um uh uh putting in place where whatever
is appropriate for their network
but why would it be appropriate to wear
a mask on a bus in london but not to
wear a mask on a train leaving london
so sure so if you think about it the the
airlines for example have already said
without any
bus as far as i saw um that you'll need
to carry on wearing masks on those i
said last week
it will be a condition of carriage for
various different transport
organizations of which tfl which tends
to
tend to have crowded commuter trains may
well
i actually said this they may well want
to have it as a condition of carriage so
it's very much in line with what we
expected even wanted to happen
on the other hand if you're on a long
distance train you're the only person in
a carriage
you know it's it's late in the evening
or something there's clearly no real
point in wearing a mask we don't want to
say that it's a it's you know you're
breaking the law by not wearing a mask
in a situation where there's absolutely
no advantage in wearing that mask so
this is very much what we expected
anticipated and said
uh shouldn't would happen so if you i
travel on an empty bus to come into sky
in the morning i should be able to get
on that bus without wearing a mask
so it depends on what that transport
organization says so if the
transport for london they're saying i
should wear that mask so should i wear
it or should i not wear that carriage
if the conditions are carriage to get on
that bus are you must have a mask on
then of course you must wear a mask it's
pretty straightforward
um but you know there's no it's pretty
straightforward it's also fairly
inconsistent though isn't it minister
well we are moving away from everything
is set in law i know we've got very used
to it the last year and a half
to a situation where we say uh actually
uh you now
um take um either responsibility
personally or in this case
you'll be told by the organization that
you are stepping into or stepping onto
in this case
uh but there may be other occasions uh
where people are asked to wear masks
because
they're being a confined uh area and
that that's quite right where
that's the point of the fourth stage of
the unlock which takes place next monday
and it will mean that people
responsibility starts to
return to people and to organizations
which is which is absolutely right
because we are
going through that on unlock stage very
cautiously
i i do want to kind of reflect on what
we saw at the weekend
at wembley and the events of the past
couple of days and the introspection
that appears to be going on within your
party at the moment about
whether or not actions words bad by some
of your colleagues may have contributed
to the racism that england's footballers
experienced
i mean do you agree with your colleague
steve baker
and when he says you know much as we
can't be associated with calls to defund
the police
we urgently need to challenge our own
attitude to people taking the knee do
you agree with them
i think it's really simple i mean racism
is abhorrent we never want to see in
society
we want to make sure that it is you know
kicked out
recognized in in all of its uh forms and
you know i thought
our england players clearly did a
brilliant job and i think
you know we should we should always
cheer them uh
and uh you know i i would i would take
issue with anybody who who says that we
shouldn't um do everything possible
to uh get rid of of of racism and and
and that's that's exactly what's
happened i i thought that the comments
about
pretty battle aren't unusual because or
odd because you know pretty patel has
spoken very moving
movingly in the house of commons about
her own experience suffering
from racism
she also referred to taking the knee as
gesture politics a view which plenty of
people in the public took and shared
and now you've got steve baker
suggesting that you need to challenge
uh the attitude within the party uh to
taking the knee
again i'll ask the question do you agree
with steve baker that perhaps
you know calling it gesture politics
wasn't the right thing to do
well my views is very simple i just
think we should respect
everybody and and in whatever form they
want to show that they are against
racism
is fine with with me and i think um
actually
it's a shame because this is detracted
from a phenomenal
uh performance by the the england team
who really
got together and and did england proud
uh and that's where i prefer to
to to to leave it i mean i think uh we
should work
all of us together in society and start
by accepting that nobody wants to see
racism and you know if you accept
everybody is coming
uh from um the right approach and
attitude
and this then we'll get a lot further as
a country and actually you know kicking
out racism
can we at least get you to agree that
perhaps we're past the point now where
politicians need to stop
telling footballers to stop commenting
on politics
well look everyone the great thing about
living in a democracy is
everybody is welcome to pitch in on this
i suppose a bit like everybody became
armchair experts about what gareth
southgate should do with his team over
over the match that i've got i think
that's i'm sorry i think the competition
is slightly a skew isn't it i mean
politicians making uh making statements
sorry footballers making statements
about food banks and racism slightly
different from armchair
you know managers commenting on the
england footballs on the internet
selection you're asking my attitude
towards it they're welcome to i mean we
live in a free society people should be
able to comment on whatever
they like and i you know actually i pay
tribute to some of the
campaigns which have raised awareness
and and uh
we live in a world where it doesn't
matter if you're a footballer
a politician a member of the public
everybody has a right to
comment on politics thank goodness
that's the world we live in uh
what what would your advice then be to
your colleague andrew rossendell who did
say perhaps
in response to tyron ming's comment
yesterday that he should be focusing on
football rather than politics
well as i said i think everybody can
comment on uh politics that's the whole
spirit of a democracy isn't it i think
it's the whole point of it
but what i would also say um is uh
you know we are absolutely united
uh as a government and i hope as a
country as well uh
boosting out racism we we abhor it
uh in fact you know in as a as a cabinet
we're more
ethnically diverse i think than any uh
in history as far as i can see
um so you know i think we're more
representative for the country in that
regard and
you know so it's it's a good thing and i
hope we can uh move on it rather united
on
on this issue because uh who wants to
live in a racist country not me
indeed and neither i am but but i do
wonder i understand it is a country mile
away from your brief there was that
meeting with the tech giants
uh between the prime ministers and the
tech giants yesterday look instagram
still seems to view monkey emojis you
know telling people to go home as
as not racist what concrete action
is the government going to be taking
about this as regards to the social
media companies
yeah i mean of course it's racist to
post or allow those sort of things to
stay online and we're introducing the
online harms bill
and that's going to have a maximum time
of 10 of
an organization's global turnover
so this is a huge uh potential
uh fine i know the prime minister had
the social media companies in
yesterday and it was very clear with
them they need to do
they are very bright companies they're
they're brilliant at
uh producing algorithms and tech and
and doing remarkable um things they need
to be monitoring their networks
a heck of a lot um more clearly uh to
make sure
that they're dealing with this racist
abuse which is to say the online harms
bill
uh will cost them dearly if they don't
minister
good to see you this morning thanks for
being with us you're welcome
i well within the past few minutes the
ons the office for national statistics
has released the monthly inflation
inflation rate for june let's speak to
our economics and data editor ed
conway who will have a view on all of
this um so what are we learning and what
does it mean
well inflation of course it's the the
measure of just how fast prices are
rising
around the economy very important
because aside from anything else
that's what the bank of england needs to
try and keep to around
two percent and the faster the economy
is growing often that pushes prices
higher
and that will cause some consternation
at bank of england and for the second
month
running inflation has risen higher than
expected let me just show you what we're
talking about here this line here shows
you inflation so again
just the rise or the indeed the change
in prices uh over the previous year you
can see it was very low in 2015 kind of
round about zero but then uh
inflation has risen uh relatively
sharply and
just recently you can see it going going
down very sharply when it came to uh the
pandemic obviously that reflects the
fact that people are spending less
uh in the shops and then rising uh very
quickly over the last few months
up to above two percent uh last time
around that was in may
but now have a look at what happened
this time around up to 2.5 percent
in june that was higher uh than
economists had expected and puts it
quite comfortably above the bank of
england's 2
target in terms of what's pushing it up
well have a look at this this breaks
down different parts of inflation and
obviously there's a lot there but let me
just kind of show you a few of the
highlights transport costs
and that includes petrol prices up quite
sharply restaurants and hotels so people
starting to go out again
spending more perhaps you've noticed
that yourselves that's also gone up
quite a lot as well as have food uh and
drinks uh
as well so you're putting up uh you're
seeing those prices kind of going up
really across
uh most categories and as a result of
that that's pushing up prices
the big question now is what the bank of
england thinks about that of course
you're seeing high prices around the
world do they look at it and say well we
need to think about what we're doing
with interest rates or do they say look
for the time being we think this is
going to pass and we can leave interest
rates at that very low level
where they are ed many thanks indeed
now the government is supposed to uh
poised to announce a statute of
limitations effectively
ending all prosecutions related to the
northern ireland
troubles it's being driven by a
commitment to end cases involving former
british soldiers
but the de facto amnesty will also apply
to former paramilitaries
the move is opposed by all five
political parties in northern ireland
the irish government
and victims on all sides as our senior
ireland correspondent david blevins
reports
the people who murdered my husband are
still walking free
i could be walking past them up a town
any day
and not know who it was it's 30 years
since the ira murdered kathleen's
husband patsy
he and five soldiers were killed when
they chained him to a van containing a
bomb
held his family at gunpoint and ordered
him to drive it into a military base
she's never seen justice but won't
accept an amnesty
well i feel robbed i feel robbed of the
whole thing because
i just feel that uh i have this thing in
my head
that when it's um an
an important person that's been killed
they're things investigated and their
things solved and
all the rest of it and we're just the
ordinary common people so it's alright
to
push us to the one side
thirteen people were shot dead when the
parachute regiment opened fire in london
daring
the case against the only veteran
charged with murder
soldier f has been halted the family of
one of his alleged victims
say a statute of limitations on
prosecutions
only adds to the pain of bloody sunday
we were just walking along just across
the road there
when we turned around we were trying to
skip the effects of gas
which i remember turning around and i
saw the powers coming on
do you think the government has made a
decision then without any
serious consideration of the views of
victims on any side um
i can't really be sure or not but what i
do know i don't trust the british
government
why not well would you trust them if
they murdered your brother and told lies
to elizabeth
with the government proposing a de facto
amnesty for veterans and
former terrorists victims like kathleen
feel they're asking too much
of those who have already paid the
highest price
the worst day that i can remember was
the day at my daughter's wedding
because her daddy should have been there
to walk her up the aisle
and i cannot say ever and never will say
that i can forgive the people who took
pets away from me
and his kids
i love patsy to the minute he died from
the day first time i met him
david blevins sky news in derry
still to come on the program with more
than 70 people now killed in the
unrest in south africa and i'll be
speaking to
ralph matega from the university of the
western cape at quarter two
at twenty past states uh we'll be
hearing from the man who was the uk's
first national security adviser lord
ricketts
and discuss yesterday's vote cutting
from eight
at quarter to nine we'll meet elise
downing he became the first woman
and the youngest person to run around
the coast of britain after struggling
with her mental health
uh some of the days other news now and
uh welsh ministers are set to announce
later whether there'll be
changes to the country's covered
restrictions first minister mark
drakeford will follow
england and scotland in announcing his
government's plans for lifting the rules
the latest data from public health wales
shows the covert case rate in wales is
136 per 100 000 people that's below
other uk nations and all english regions
demonstrators have gathered in miami and
washington in support of protesters in
cuba
they're calling for president miguel
diaz-canel to resign
amidst country-wide restrictions on
social media and messaging platforms
and for the u.s president to offer more
support to the country
it comes after widespread protests on
sunday against cuba's economic crisis
and its handling of the pandemic
england defender harry maguire has
revealed that his father suffered
suspected broken ribs and was left
struggling to breathe
after ticketless fans breached the
security at wembley
before the euro 2020 final maguire told
the sun newspaper that what happened was
scary and added that his family will be
more aware when attending games in
future
well yesterday uefa opened a
disciplinary investigation into the
incidents at wembley
there's been sweltering temperatures
across california
as a heatwave widely blamed on climate
change has a fun grip on america's
largest state
and shows no signs of easing well last
month was the
hottest june ever in north america
and dozens of wildfires continue to burn
across the west coast
with the two largest in northeastern
california and southern oregon
fires in neighboring states are
threatening california's power grids
and energy operators have asked
residents to conserve electricity
to avoid outages over the weekend palm
springs in southern california hit
a record high temperature of 49 degrees
celsius where our u.s correspondent greg
milam
sent this report
[Music]
109 today not bad especially considering
that we were 120 in palm springs on
saturday
the weather forecasters do it in
fahrenheit in america 120
is 48 celsius however you measure it
even for the desert city of palm springs
it's extreme
and it was 130 in death valley so mike
everett's been reporting record
temperatures for days
and the hottest june ever here he sees
drastic choices ahead
it's climate change pure and simple
places like this
may become uninhabitable at least in the
summer time
when you talk about the potential for
130 degree heat
for prolonged periods of time people
will just move
we'll migrate very similar to like we
did at the beginning of mankind
we're going to get away from the
equators and start
inhabiting the north you know if you're
looking to invest in real estate
greenland is a great place to look right
now
for now it means adapting carlos has
shifted his work to earlier in the day
when it's at least a bit cooler living
out here in general
the people the everybody kind of has
already acclimated to it you know and if
we can't
work in this heat then we can't just
stay at home you know i mean
do you feel it's getting hotter though
definitely yeah
it feels like what the scientists warn
of more frequent and intense heat waves
has already arrived patrick and ryan
have just moved to palm springs
it does seem to be getting hotter um the
waves that we've had more recently
are much earlier in the year than
typical we won't get this hot until
around august sometimes or maybe
september and previous years
so having that and they're pro not as
prolonged like
these heat waves usually like three or
four days and now we've been getting
these high pressure
systems that that last for a week like
this current when we're in we're like
day three of nine so it's going to be
this intense for a while
and across the west with drought and
heat come the fires
this year getting bigger earlier than
usual there isn't a fire season anymore
it's year round
california is a place that's led the way
in the move towards renewable energy
and its inhabitants are on the front
line when it comes to the dramatic
effects of climate change
here where they idolize the star of the
movie some like it hot
how much more will anyone be able to
stand
greg milam sky news palm springs in
california
well for much more related news don't
forget the daily climate show that's on
sky news every weekday
half past six and half past night
uh time now to see how the weather is
looking domestically and it is starting
to get hotter at nas standing by
uh how hot could it get today uh yeah
around the country
well it's going to be yeah very warm
today across many areas we could easily
see temperatures
in the early to mid 20s but as we head
into the weekend for some spots we could
also reach heat wave criteria here in
the uk
and ireland
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning to you so fine and dry all
in all for many parts of the uk and
ireland for the rest of this week
we're going to see plenty of sunshine
the warmth will be building
it's going to feel hot as we head into
the weekend with some spots reaching
heatwave criteria until then a couple of
days of
nuisance cloud to contend with this
morning eastern areas quite cloudy and
murky with a little bit of drizzle some
showers across western scotland
otherwise mainly dry and bright
and there will be lots of sunshine this
afternoon for most of scotland england
and wales
eastern areas will see that cloud melt
away but it may take some time for east
anglia to brighten up but it will
eventually however across ireland
northern ireland
western scotland a weak front
approaching bringing cloudier skies
and some patchy drizzle
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
still to come we'll be asking at
london's mayor city can why he's keeping
mass going mandatory on public transport
in the city coming soon
[Music]
welcome back in the last few minutes the
transport secretary told the programme
that the government expects and even
wants different companies and travel
networks to adopt different rules on
masks after the 19th of july
on monday in england the legal
requirement for masks will be dropped
but the maid of london will keep the
requirement for mass on public
transports in
and around the capital grant sharp says
there are
there is no issue with rules differing
in different places
i said last week it will be a condition
of carriage
for various different transport
organizations of which
tfl which tends to tend to have crowded
commuter trains
may well i actually said this they may
well want to have it as a condition
of carriage so uh it's very much in line
with what we
expected even wanted to happen on the
other hand if you're on a long distance
train you're the only person in a
carriage
you know it's it's it's late in the
evening or something there's clearly no
real point in wearing a mask we didn't
want to
say that it's you know you're breaking
the law by not wearing a mask in a
situation where there's absolutely no
advantage in wearing that mask so
this is very much what we expected
anticipated and said
uh shouldn't would happen if the
conditions of carriage to get on that
bus are you must have a mask on
then of course you must wear a mask it's
pretty straightforward
let's bring in our political
correspondent tamara cohen i'm
straightforward it may be but it occurs
to me that there are perhaps lots of
people traveling alone late at night on
trains the prime minister mentioned that
example stephen barkley mentioned it
yesterday
and now the transport secretary but
there is a degree of
well confusion yes there is because
we're now in a situation where mask
wearing in england will no longer be
compulsory so
but it will be a condition of carriage
on the underground so if you're getting
you're underground you have to wear your
mask or the tube or the bus
and then you might go to houston station
and get a mainline train where you don't
have to
wear your mask although it's encouraged
if it's busy but if you're getting that
train to
wales you will have to wear a mask
because there it is it remains the law
although they're going to be further
announcements there later this week so
you've got to try and keep a handle on
the different rules in different places
and
still many shops are unclear about
whether they can say
don't you don't have to wear a mask from
monday as well i think
a lot of people would say why don't they
just keep them compulsory because that
would make things
simpler the government's feeling was
that they didn't want to stick with
these rigid rules on masks but certainly
the the impression you get from some
conservative mps is that while
um they don't like it the the public
seem to support wearing
masks that's what the polls suggest and
that this may be somewhere where they
will have to be a u-turn further down
the line
demarc for now thanks very much uh well
let's turn our attention to the
situation in london the personalities
announced the changes this morning at
the mayor of london sadiq khan just a
short walk away from where i'm standing
uh good to see you this morning mayor
thanks for being on the program and
just if you can explain the rationale
behind the mandatory wedding of mass and
transport in london
well tfl is arguably one of the safest
and cleanest
transit authorities in the world we're
using world-class enhanced cleaning
we're using hospital quality
disinfectant we've got more than a
thousand hand sanitizers we're using
uv light to make sure our escalators are
safe we're also asking imperial college
to come and make sure
there's no covet on public transport
they found no evidence of coving or the
testing they've done
but i think after monday we should
continue making it uh compulsory
to wear a face mask on public transport
where often you can't keep your social
distance it adds an additional layer of
protection but also
reassurance the evidence we know from
the government's own
scientific advices the evidence from the
world health organization
is you are in a face mask makes it less
likely
that the virus can be passed on it
reduces transmission in an indoor space
where you can't keep your distance but
also the center for disease control in
the usa have now said
actually on top of it being the most
unselfish thing you can do
we're in a face mask may reduce the
chances of you catching the virus so for
me
it's really important that we make sure
public transport continues to be both
safe but also reassuring how confident
are you though that londoners will
will heed uh the tfl guidance i i mean
at the plural of anecdote is not
evidence of course
but my travels on public transport last
week would certainly suggest
that already in the aftermath of the
announcement about july the 19th there
are a lot of people
choosing not to wear masks
yeah that's why i was keen to come out
today before monday
and make it clear what the expectation
is going to be after monday which is a
continuation
of it being obligatory to wear a face
mask when you're using
transport in london the good news is
uh from survey work we've done over the
last year
roughly speaking 86 86 of people using
public transport in london
are we in face coverings and of the 14
who aren't
about two-thirds are either exempt or
have a good reason my message to anybody
not just in london
but those visiting our cities it is
going to be compulsory store from next
monday
to our face cover and actually you know
what's the most unselfish thing you can
do
it means that there's less chance if
you've got the virus and by the way
one out of three people who've got the
virus won't show any symptoms
it reduces the chance of you passing it
on is there going to be
robust enforcement of this are we going
to see bus drivers kicking people off
buses not letting them all in the first
place
tfl employees being asked to confront
people
at train stations or is this simply just
a statement of intent if the maid of
london says wear your masks on public
transport
there is a greater likelihood that
people will wear masks on public
transport
well what i've examined over the last
year what's been going on in
london and roughly speaking there have
been 212
000 conversations between tfl
enforcement officers
and members of the public by and large
members of the public putting their face
masks in their pocket or their purse
they've forgotten
it's not quite covering their nose or
sometimes they'll go to the shop and get
one before they get on a bus
or a network actually there's only been
4 000
fixed penalty notices issued so what
you're going to be seeing from
monday is we've got hundreds of tfl
enforcement officers they'll be there to
make sure
people are following the rules but if
you come to a station or you want to go
on a bus
and you haven't got a face covering you
may not be allowed on without face
covering unless you're exempt
if you're on one of our trains tubes
buses ducklings like railway
overground trains tfl rail and uh
you'll see not to have a face mask and
you've not got a good reason and you
aren't exempt
you'll be asked to leave so can i just
just dwell on this topic just for a
second i think there's around about 400
tfl enforcement
officers as you say thousands of of
penalties have been issued i think
just a little bit less than 5 000. that
strikes me that's one a month over the
past year
for each of those enforcement officers
are we going to see
more penalty notices handed out
i hope not because you know what the
evidence is is londoners and those
visiting our city have done the right
thing
and not just the huge sacrifices made
over the last 16 months but over the
last 12 months
making the right choice to wear a face
mask without the need
for enforcement to take place but if
there is a need for greater enforcement
there's a need for
more tearful enforcement officers will
look into that at the same time we're
exploring
uh making this a bylaw that'll mean we
can use both the police service
in london but also british transport
police but you know the evidence i've
seen
is people doing the right thing you know
brits and londoners get it and they want
to be unselfish they want to
avoid the chance minimize the chance of
them passing the virus but also they're
well aware
that amongst us there are people with
clinical vulnerabilities there are some
of us whose immunity is suppressed
we don't want them to be not being able
to use an essential service like public
transport and so i'm confident
londoners and those visionaries will do
the right thing i i want to talk about
what happened in and around
uh wembley in just a second but perhaps
we could focus on what followed
the football on on sunday and you know
tyrone mings and and others actually
within the england setup have suggested
that perhaps people in including the
home secretary pretty patel
fueled the fire uh in terms of the
racist abuse that they received i'm sure
that in the past you may well have in
private referred to the conservatives as
the nasty party
i'm just wondering whether you think
that a racist party
well let me be quite clear one of the
reasons
why the likes of marcus rashford raheem
sterling and others felt so strongly
about black lives matter and support
with the movement
was to say no to racism and one of the
reasons why the likes of harry maguire
harry kane and others supported their
colleagues when it came to taking the
knee
was to show solidarity uh in their fight
against
racism and i think when people boo that
boo their own team it begs the question
about some of their motives and do not
condemn
boone of uh our players taking the knee
to not condemn that i think uh
doesn't bode well but also you know what
harry kane's not a marxist
harry mcguire doesn't want to defund the
police these are
colleagues showing solidarity to
their black mates in the squad and i'm
really proud of the squad i'm really
proud of gareth southgate i'm really
proud of the team
and those who have been hurling racist
abused online
stands or on the street should be uh
disgusted and i'm sure the police will
be taking action
in terms of what we saw at wembley and
indeed what we saw in the west end uh
cameron mackintosh complaining about the
windham theater you know requiring
essentially millions of pounds worth of
repairs because of the behavior of fans
why do we keep hearing so many people
say that they have full confidence in
crested decks running of the
metropolitan police
well the responsibility for the fans in
leicester square
in liverpool street outside wembley
stadium
in parts of london lies with the
hooligans and it's really important that
they're held to account
more than 86 arrests already been made
19 of our police officers were
injured and the police are going through
both cctv footage
are going through body worn videos are
looking at the evidence and more charges
will be
brought because the sort of hooliganism
you saw on sunday isn't acceptable then
it's really important they're brought to
book
but there are no questions about crested
dicks continuing
as head of the met
well no she's got almost a year left of
her contract she's got my full
confidence
it's for the commissioner to decide
whether she wants a second term let's
cross that bridge when it comes to it
but it's really important that we
support the police
in relation to catching those criminals
responsible for this sort of behavior
on a sunday as far as i'm concerned
they're not real fans
and it's really really really important
if anybody's got information about any
hooligans on
sunday then let the police know because
we want justice to happen
this elite can good to see you this
morning thanks for being with us
stay safe now a recent review of the
equality act suggests that the uk's
legislation
lags behind other countries the review
board are calling for urgent reforms to
policy surrounding race
disability religion and sex
the chief executive of the equality act
review dr surya b
joins us now dr b great to see you this
morning thanks for taking the time to
talk to us
just just explain exactly and what in
what ways the uk equality act is
is falling around while it's falling
behind comparable
compatible countries good morning
thank you so much for having me here
today
the equality act review today publishes
its report titled
equality act 10 years on we have
conducted the largest
and the most comprehensive review of the
act in its 10
year history now one of the findings
that we
put forward is that it lags behind as
you rightly said
other countries such as america
south africa canada intersectionality
dual discrimination is one of the ways
it lags behind
we as human beings are complex we do not
present as
a single identity at a time we are more
than one identity as often
but in our courts of law we only can
present
one form of discrimination at a time so
for example
i would not be able to argue that i have
been discriminated against
because i am a muslim woman
who is also of kashmiri uh background
um i have to argue those things
individually
uh another aspect of the act that is
lagging
behind is the exclusivity of the act
its current protected characteristics um
are very narrow um they are mainly
rooted in biology and ignore
social economic social cultural identity
now we have had
a large uh a wealth of studies that have
come
forward uh regarding accent bias
regarding weight bias um regarding
hair discrimination um a lot of students
and
employees are being sent home uh from
work and school because
um there's a belief that they had the
way their hair
is is worn especially by black persons
um
is not in line with uniform policy so we
ask
for the act to include new and added
protected characteristics
but also to strengthen current protected
characteristics
such as sex you know the the unfortunate
very sad
um murder of sarah everard
in earlier in the year we we saw
misogyny becoming a hate crime
that that's protection in the streets
but it does not yet translate
um as protection in the workplace
doctor but i don't want us to run out of
time but i do want to to know whether or
not your own personal experiences
have informed your work uh or on the
equality act
absolutely unfortunately i was dismissed
um
for raising a concern around 11 year old
children being
taught being shown a graphic video of
people jumping to their deaths
i went to the employment tribunals the
judge ruled that
it is not religious discrimination
because a
um a jewish or a christian woman would
have been treated
the same way my argument was that no
they would not have been treated the
same way you need to look at
context you need to look at rising
islamophobia
in the west and in the uk and without a
lot of the context surrounding
discrimination against muslims in
particular those experiences that
discrimination would not have been
subjected to
um women or men over the fates at this
moment in time regarding
a video to do with 9 11. all right dr
sirabi i'm afraid we have to leave it
there but good to see you this morning
thanks for joining us
did you know symptoms of hay fever can
develop at any stage of life
not just in childhood the pollen reports
sponsored by philips connected air
purifiers
most of scotland england and wales will
be dry with warm spells of sunshine
today however island northern ireland
and western scotland
will become cloudier with some light
rain and drizzle
with the mostly fine weather pollen
levels will be high or very high for all
but the north of scotland where it'll be
moderate today
we're in the peak of the grass and spore
pollen season while nettle
is at a medium risk
the pollen reports sponsored by philips
connected air purifiers
and i know that many of you be watching
from south africa this morning
to those who are not there well you may
not be aware it is currently in the
midst of its worst unrest since the end
of apartheid
the area around the kwazullah natal and
guantang provinces have witnessed scenes
of
looting firing and chaotic stampedes
that have seen a death toll rise to more
than
70 people over 1200 arrests have also
been made
as the violence sparked by the jailing
of the ex-president jacob zuma
continues uh pleased to say we're joined
now by ralph matega a researcher
at the university of western cape ralph
thanks very much for joining us this
morning
you will have heard me just a moment ago
mention jacob zuma's name to what extent
from from your perspective
is this to do with his jailing
good morning and thanks for having me um
the jacob zuma meta of course
triggered what we've seen happening the
standoff between
uh jacob zuma and the justice system uh
his supporters during the justice system
that his incarceration
will result in the country becoming
ungovernable this is what she got
the whole thing however it needs to be
noted that the scale
at which this has happened and the
intensity of this in the last few days
goes beyond jacob zuma it is about
people also
willing to partake in such kind of
activities and in my view
it goes also to the social economic
conditions in the country that
practically you do have young people
available to participate in these
young people who come out as having
nothing to lose immediately
because of the socio-economic condition
because of a sense of
disenchantment with the current system
under the anc now
how has the anc moved in this direction
moved so far in this direction
we understand of course that south
africa still has significant
socioeconomic problems particularly
in terms of the economy and you have
someone like jacob zuma accused
and convicted of uh well behaviour in
office
unfit for a man of his position
it's quite an irony that a struggle to
support
mr zuma resulted in some looting whereas
he's actually accused of
looting resources in the country i mean
this is a cause that
lacks any moral basis and no doubt about
it that
you cannot expedite mr zuma's situation
any other way
the attempt is to try to pressure the
court so that mr zuma can be released
and
this will put into dupady the principle
of the rule of law
in the country and i think it also has
to do with the anc
the poor level of leadership the
declining credibility of the anc
as a political party despite the fact
that they won election
uh the credibility and the legitimacy to
make decision
to reign in uh behavior in our society
is quite a problem thereof and also the
deadline of local leadership all of
these things
are also happening because of just the
decline of local leadership
across communities among communities in
the country uh
from your in your mind what are the
chances of us seeing the frustration
and indeed the violence and criminality
spreading from kwazulu-natal uh granting
to
other provinces in south africa
south africans uh majority of south
africans are not really interested in
partaking in this
uh majority of south africans are not
members of the anc
and they see this as a something that
originates from within the anc
and i think that is why in other
provinces communities have taken a
position where they've said that
we are not going to be part of this we
are not going to destroy
uh prospect for jobs we are not going to
destroy the livelihood just because of
one man
so we have seen this thing abating it is
actually being de-escalated this morning
and the bigger part of it is not because
the armies out there that it is
de-escalating
it is largely because of the communities
taking their position
and saying that not in our name we are
not going to allow this
among our communities in areas across
the township
communities have come out last night
some stood in
night vigil actually protecting some of
the shopping centers
that i think is bringing a huge effect
in
the escalation of this ralph what does
this mean for the future of the anc and
indeed for the future of south africa
i think south africans are going to have
to deeply think about the relationship
that they have with the nc
they're going to have to think about the
future and the future of the country
might not involve the prominence of the
anc
i think that going into the next
election this is going to come to bear
a lot of people are quite angry towards
the anc
young people are speaking on various
television networks
saying that this is all because of the
anc and it's not worth it it is not a
course that is actually worth
their efforts uh ralph mctaker really
good to speak to you this morning thanks
for being with us
great pleasure
time for the weather
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning it is looking all in all
fine for the rest of this week we're
going to see plenty of fine
dry weather some good spells of sunshine
and it will be warming up for some spots
we could reach
heat wave criteria as we head into the
weekend from around friday onwards until
then a couple of days of nuisance cloud
to contend with eastern parts of the uk
this morning for example
rather cloudy and murky with some
drizzly bits of rain and across western
parts of scotland a few showers there
otherwise
mainly dry and bright and fairly muggy
too now there'll be plenty of sunshine
to this afternoon across
scotland england and wales and to begin
with across parts of ireland and
northern ireland
but it will turn increasingly cloudy
across parts of the west of ireland and
northern ireland by around midday and
then
further east as their weak front spreads
its way eastwards reaching western
scotland
by this evening with some patchy light
rain and drizzle elsewhere
warm and sunny
the weather sponsored by qatar airways